y
[Música]
la farmacéutica moderna anunció que su
vacuna es efectiva contra las nuevas
variantes de kobe 19 identificadas por
primera vez en reino unido y sudáfrica
sin embargo la compañía dijo que está
trabajando en una vacuna de refuerzo
contra la variante sudafricana en la que
se produjo una respuesta inmune más
débil
el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador se encuentra bajo
tratamiento médico tras dar positivo por
corona virus el mandatario de 67 años
reportó síntomas leves pero preocupa a
los expertos por su historial de
problemas cardíacos el contagio se
produjo en la semana más letal de la
pandemia para mexico que ya roza los 150
mil muertos
se cumple el décimo aniversario del
inicio de la revolución egipcia parte de
la primavera árabe que sacó del poder a
hosni mubarak a 10 años de las masivas
movilizaciones el país vive bajo la
sombra del gobierno militar de abdel
fattah al sisi que llegó al poder tras
el golpe de estado en 2013 tenemos
información desde el cairo
feliz inicio de semana y bienvenidos a
un nuevo informativo de france 24 los
saluda andrés meza muñoz el laboratorio
estadounidense moderna indicó que su
vacuna contra el kobe 19 es efectiva
contra las variantes británica y
sudafricana del virus no obstante los
responsables de la farmacéutica
señalaron que usarán un refuerzo del
fármaco en ensayo preclínico para
determinar si sería mayor la efectividad
para producir anticuerpos contra la
variante sudafricana y futuras variantes
por su parte el laboratorio
estadounidense merck anunció que frenó
el desarrollo de dos vacunas anti kobe
creemos que es imperativo ser proactivos
a medida que el virus evoluciona estamos
promoviendo una candidata de refuerzo
contra la variante identificada por
primera vez en la república de sudáfrica
para determinar si será más efectivo
aumentar los títulos contra ésta y
posibles variantes futuras
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador dio positivo por kobe 19
mientras su país uno de los más
afectados del mundo por la pandemia
afronta una segunda ola de la enfermedad
que deja en la nación más de 1,7
millones de contagios y cerca de 150.000
muertos un vistazo a la gestión de la
pandemia de lópez obrador en el
siguiente informe de natalia plazas
es uno más de los 17 millones de
mexicanos contagiados
el presidente del país andrés manuel
lópez obrador dio positivo por el
coronavirus el mandatario ha sido
fuertemente criticado por la gestión que
ha hecho de la pandemia de coronavirus
en el país
desde el inicio de la emergencia
minimizó su impacto siento que no vamos
a atender problemas mayores y mientras
otros países de la región imponían
restricciones su administración se
resistía no dejen
salir todavía estamos en la primera fase
ya nosotros yo les voy a decir cuando no
salga a pesar de haber sufrido un
infarto y padecer hipertensión rara vez
se le ha visto con una mascarilla en
público a lo largo de la pandemia ha
continuado sus viajes y mítines por
diferentes puntos del país y ha seguido
saludando a sus simpatizantes con
apretones de manos y abrazos donde el
coronavirus esos de que éste no se puede
uno abrazar hay que abrazarse si no pasa
nada o sea éste
así promovió dudosos métodos para una
supuesta protección ante el contagio de
este ente
detente
ahora ambos se une a otros líderes
mundiales que han contraído la
enfermedad como el ex presidente
estadounidense donald trump el
presidente brasileño jair bolsonaro o el
primer ministro británico boris johnson
también ellos restaron importancia al
impacto del virus y se negaron al inicio
de la pandemia a imponer restricciones
el primer caso de la enfermedad se
detectó a finales de febrero en ese país
menos de un año después ya suma 150.000
muertes por corona virus méxico es la
cuarta nación a nivel mundial con mayor
número de muertes por esa enfermedad
europa ya superó los 32 millones de
contagios de kobe 19 en francia el
gobierno baraja un posible tercer
confinamiento que según la recomendación
de los expertos debería iniciar en
febrero para evitar una situación
extremadamente difícil a mediados de
marzo el reino unido al primer ministro
boris johnson analiza endurecer los
controles fronterizos ante el riesgo de
nuevas variantes de la vacuna que las
vacunas no puedan combatir la comisión
europea sugirió a los países de la unión
europea que recomiendan no viajar desde
ni hacia áreas de alto riesgo de
expansión de la pandemia desde bruselas
nuestra corresponsal esther herrera nos
amplía la información
la unión europea quiere evitar que se
descontroló por completo la situación
por la tercera ola del coronavirus en la
unión europea por ello apunta a los
viajes dentro de sus fronteras la
comisión europea propone aislar a la
práctica a todas las zonas y países con
incidencia acumulada de 500 casos por
100.000 habitantes algo que afectaría
especialmente a españa y portugal a
todos los viajeros que provengan de
estas zonas se les obligará a que tengan
un test en negativo antes de viajar y se
les obligará a una cuarentena a su país
de llegada
tampoco se descartara un segundo test
para evitar casos en que se pueda
importar el virus la comisión europea
quiere evitar a toda costa que la gente
pueda viajar dentro de la unión europea
con una especial atención a las nuevas
variantes también se vigilará a los
pasajeros que provengan de países donde
ya se han confirmado los casos lo que
quiere la unión europea es sobre todo
por una parte evitar los viajes y a la
vez también vigilar a las nuevas
variantes mucho más peligrosas debido a
su mayor transmisibilidad
además este momento es muy delicado para
la unión europea en plena campaña de
vacunación especialmente ahora que
astrazéneca y también facer ya han dicho
que no cumplirán con el calendario de
producción y esto podría retrasar
muchísimo más la campaña de vacunación
dentro de la unión europea
cambiamos de tema y vamos a egipto que
cumple 10 años del surgimiento de las
masivas protestas callejeras que sacaron
del poder al entonces presidente hosni
mubarak
a continuación una mirada retrospectiva
a los eventos que se han desarrollado en
la última década
plaza tahir el corazón del levantamiento
popular de egipto a partir del 25 de
enero de 2011 miles de manifestantes se
reunieron bajo la atenta mirada del
ejército pidiendo un cambio inmediato
durante lo que llamaron un día de rabia
bajo la creciente presión de las
protestas callejeras el presidente hosni
mubarak renunció y salió del cairo con
su familia el 11 de febrero espero que
algún día esta revolución de enero pueda
traernos lo que hemos pedido ban
libertad justicia social y dignidad se
celebraron elecciones legislativas para
la sorpresa de todos los islamistas
obtuvieron dos tercios de los escaños de
los diputados en un punto de inflexión
histórico el candidato de los hermanos
musulmanes mohamed morsi se convirtió en
el primer presidente elegido
democráticamente
mors y prestó juramento el 30 de junio
de 2012 sólo unas semanas después del
juicio sin precedentes de mubarak pero
este breve experimento de democracia
terminó en julio de 2013 con el
derrocamiento y arresto de morse
a pesar de las protestas en las calles
un nuevo régimen autoritario respaldado
por el ejército tomó el control en mayo
de 2014 por el 97% de los votos el ex
ministro de defensa el general
abdelfatah al sisi fue elegido
presidente el parlamento a doctor
rápidamente una nueva constitución que
fortalecía los poderes del ejército una
al cis y envalentonado lanzó una feroz
campaña para reprimir las voces
disidentes
las ong denunciaron violaciones a los
derechos humanos tras la detención de
miles de partidarios de morse una década
después de la revolución a pesar de una
mejora en la economía las ambiciones
democráticas de egipto aún no se han
cumplido pero su economía ha recibido un
impulso
la justicia ugandesa ordenó que el
cantante y activista bobby wine sea
liberado de su arresto domiciliario el
tribunal superior de kampala pidió a las
fuerzas de seguridad que se retiren de
la residencia del que también fue
candidato a la presidencia en las
elecciones del pasado 14 de enero
desde entonces wine no ha podido salir
de su casa desde donde ha instado a sus
seguidores a protestar contra el
resultado de los comicios tras la
reciente orden desde el juez el cantante
denunció que los agentes todavía rodean
su domicilio
vamos a china donde las autoridades
informaron que encontraron los restos de
nueve de los 22 mineros que habían
quedado atrapados tras una explosión en
una mina en la provincia de shandong el
pasado 10 de enero ayer 11 de ellos
fueron rescatados sanos y salvos y ya se
había confirmado la muerte de uno de los
miembros del grupo con este nuevo
hallazgo se eleva a 10 el número de
fallecidos y aún se desconoce el
paradero y la suerte de uno de los
mineros
hasta aquí este informativo de france 24
pero recuerden que pueden seguir la
actualización de nuestras noticias en
nuestra página web www france24 puntocom
quédense con nosotros
[Música]